"SPECIAL REPORT" IS UP NEXT.
>> Bret: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT ACCUSED OF
KILLING AT CALIFORNIA POLICE
OFFICER HAS BEEN CAPTURED AND WE
ARE LEARNING THAT THIS WAS NOT
HIS FIRST ARREST.
GOOD EVENING, I'M BRET BAIER.
THE SUSPECT WAS CAUGHT JUST A
FEW HOURS AGO NEAR BAKERSFIELD,
CALIFORNIA, AFTER BEING ON THE
RUN FOR TWO DAYS.
INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE HE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MURDER OF
NEWMAN POLICE OFFICER RONIL
SINGH WHO MIGRATED TO THE U.S.
LEGALLY.
IN AN EMOTIONAL CONFERENCE THIS
AFTERNOON, THE STANISLAUS
SHERIFFS THAT THINGS COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED.
ALL THIS HAPPENING AS WE HEAD
INTO A LONG WEEKEND WITH A
STALEMATE OVER THE FIGHT OVER
BORDER SECURITY.
FOX TEAM COVERAGE TONIGHT AND
ALLISON BARBER IS AT THE
WHITE HOUSE WHERE THE PRESIDENT
IS THREATENING TO CLOSE THE U.S.
BORDER.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY IS ON
CAPITOL HILL WERE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE NOT, BUT WE BEGIN
WITH NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT
WILLIAM LODGE AND IS WHO IS
FOLLOWING ALL THE LATEST OF
ELEMENTS FROM LOS ANGELES.
GOOD EVENING, WILLIAM.
>> JUST HOURS AGO, THE REST WAS
CONFIRMED OF GUSTAVO ARRIAGA, A
CONVICTED DRUNK DRIVER WITH
OUTSTANDING WARRANTS.
THE CALIFORNIA SHERIFF ALSO
CONFIRMING THE ARREST OF TWO
OTHER ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, A
BROTHER AND COWORKER WHO TRIED
TO COVER THE LOCATION OF ARRIAGA
AS HE TRIED TO FLEE TO MEXICO.
BUT AT THE SURVEILLANCE TEAM
INTERSECTED HIM NEAR BAKERSFIELD
WHERE HE SURRENDERED WITHOUT
INCIDENT.
HE IS THE MEXICAN NATIONAL WHO
ENTER THE U.S. ILLEGALLY IN
ARIZONA, WANTED FOR KILLING
33-YEAR-OLD RONIL SINGH, WHO
EMIGRATED LEGALLY FROM FIJI.
HE WAS MARRIED WITH A
5-MONTH-OLD SON AND HE TOOK THIS
PHOTO CHRISTMAS DAY, JUST HOURS
BEFORE HE AND HIS K-9 PARTNER
STOPPED A POSSIBLE DRUNK DRIVER.
MOMENTS LATER, HE RADIOED TO,
SHOTS FIRED, I'M HIT.
HE DIED A SHORT TIME LATER.
TODAY HIS BROTHER REGGIE THANKED
POLICE FOR FINDING HIS KILLER.
>> HE'S NOT COMING BACK, BUT --
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT
THERE.
THAT MISS HIM AND A LOT OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHO WORK DAYS AND
NIGHTS TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
>> TODAY IN A NEWS CONFERENCE,
THE SHERIFF OF STANISLAUS COUNTY
THROUGH GASOLINE ON THE ALREADY
RED-HOT IMMIGRATION DEBATE BY
CALLING SINGH'S DEATH
PREVENTABLE, BLAMING THE STATE
SANCTUARY LAW FROM PROHIBITING
POLICE FROM COMMUNICATING WITH
I.C.E. ABOUT KNOWN AND WANTED
FELONS.
>> LET'S GO BACK TO RON.
AN IMMIGRANT WHO IMMIGRATED HERE
LAWFULLY AND ILLEGALLY TO PURSUE
HIS AMERICAN DREAM.
HE ACHIEVED THAT GOAL.
HIS DREAM WAS TAKEN FROM HIM.
NO, WE SHOULDN'T POLITICIZE IT,
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT RESTRICTIVE
LEGISLATION THAT PUTS OUR
COMMUNITIES AT RISK.
>> WHEN YOU TIE OUR HANDS AND
DON'T ALLOW US TO WORK WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS AND COMMUNICATE
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS ABOUT
PEOPLE THAT COMMIT CRIMES WHO
ARE IN THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY,
WE HAVE INCIDENCES LIKE THIS.
>> Bret: POLICE ARRESTED THREE
MORE FOR AIDING AND ABETTING